[MUSIC PLAYING]
EVAN JONES: Good
morning, everybody.
Thank you all for getting
up here very early
on the very last day
of the conference
for the exciting
topic of billing.
I'm glad that you all
realize how important it
is to actually understand
what it costs your business
to run your software.
Lots of people don't understand
how important this topic is.
Usually, they think
it's really boring.
So I'm glad that you
actually understand.
My name's Evan Jones.
I'm a software
engineer at Bluecore.
And we're going to talk today
about going beyond your bill
and getting more detail on cost.
So first, we're going to talk
a little bit about Bluecore's
cost challenges and how
I got involved in this.
We're then going to talk
about Google's existing cost
management tools, what they
give you out of the box.
We're then going
to talk about how
you can create some of
your own data sources
when you need more detail on
what things are costing you.
And then finally, we're going
to talk a little bit about some
of the lessons that we've
learned at Bluecore about this.
And we're going to have
plenty of time for Q&A
because I tend to
talk way too quickly.
All right, so first, the
reason I got involved in this,
is I started getting all
these questions, like hey,
why is our bill so high?
Why did February
cost us $123,000?
Or hey, why did our bill go up?
Why does February cost $23,000
more than what January did?
Or what happened on this day?
What happened on October
25th to cause our cost
to be really high?
Just a quick show of
hands, has anybody
here had to answer questions
like that for your business?
All right, great.
The rest of you,
don't worry, though.
Someone in your
company will eventually
figure out that you
do, in fact, know
how to answer these questions
because every single
organization needs
to know the answer
to these sorts of questions.
Great.
So why did we get here?
So Bluecore, we are a
six-year-old startup.
We do intelligent
e-commerce marketing.
We've been around for six
years, based in New York.
We now have about 180 employees.
Our customers are hundreds
of large retailers.
So we are a software as
a service application.
And we sell to customers
like Sephora, Express,
Tommy Hilfiger, and
other brands that I'm
sure you would recognize.
The company started
with the intention
of saying that email
marketing for e-commerce
isn't really being
done correctly.
The traditional approach
is a retailer just sends
the same content to every
single customer that's
ever shopped on their website.
And Bluecore started
with the intention
of, we should customize
that and provide people
information that's actually
relevant to them in this email.
So, as an example of
what that looks like,
here's an email that
we send for Timberland.
It says other popular purchases
and it has three suggested
products at the bottom.
The point of this is a message
that the marketer, Timberland,
has configured to send
to their customers
after they've
completed a purchase.
And then these
products that are shown
at the bottom come from our
recommendation algorithms.
And so these have been
customized for the recipient
of this email.
Maybe it's based on the
product that they already
purchased or some of the
other shopping history
that they may have
with this retailer.
So these types of personalized
messages are more effective.
But there is a disadvantage.
And the disadvantage is, this
is what our Google Cloud cost
bill looks like.
In all of the slides
in this presentation,
I've had to remove the actual
dollar values on the y-axis
here.
So you'll have to apologize,
but this is, in fact,
our real Google Cloud bill.
This is our top level
bill, daily cost
starting in January 1, 2017
through until February of 2019.
This is as much data as
the built in Google Cloud
billing console would give us.
Now because of some of
these spikes in variations,
it may not be extremely
obvious, but this is actually
a 3x increase over two years.
So this is 75% annual growth.
Now for me, this is a
great problem to have.
As an engineer, I
love this because this
means we've got to go now and
figure out how to optimize
this and solve this.
It also means that our
business is growing.
So this is actually a
really good problem to have.
But we do want to make
sure that our growth is
in line with our
business, or ideally,
actually grows slower than our
actual growth in our business,
right?
Which would improve the
profitability of the business.
So because this
has happened, we've
needed to start looking into
all of these questions, like OK,
so why is our bill so high?
Where is that money going?
The top level cost like
this doesn't actually
show you a whole
lot of information,
besides hey, you're spending
more money than you used to.
But I do think it's interesting.
There are a few interesting
trends you can see here.
So at this far left mark here
at around November or December
of 2017 is Black Friday.
We have a very
seasonal business.
People do a lot of shopping
starting between Thanksgiving
and the end of the year.
And so that spike there is
their increase for 2017.
We have an extremely
large peak there,
which is in about October.
That was when we went and did
load testing for Black Friday.
We want to make sure
that every year,
we can handle the load
that we're going to see.
We go and try to
break our own systems.
It turns out that cost
a little bit of money.
So that's what that
particular spike
is for on that particular day.
And then you can see
Black Friday 2018.
So you can see
here for Bluecore,
we tend to have this thing
where our costs kind of go up,
and then they go up a heck of
a lot starting in November.
And then they kind of
stay at that level.
And then they go up
the next November,
and then they kind of
stay at that level.
OK.
Great.
So when we had these questions
about cost when we were smaller
with about 10
software engineers,
we would just go to the all
hands meeting and be like, hey,
where did our cost
increase come from?
Last Thursday, something
must have happened.
Our data store cost is up.
Our app engine cost
is up, whatever.
Did somebody do something?
And usually, somebody there
would be like, oh, yep.
I think we turned on
this new data feature.
Let me go looking to
see if that's what's
causing the cost increase.
We could go find it
and solve the problem.
Now that we're bigger, we have
about 40 or so engineers, that
doesn't actually work anymore.
We have too many changes
and too much complexity.
So when we go and ask that
question at the all hands
meeting, people are
just like, I've no idea.
We changed all sorts of things.
Maybe one of our
customers started
using a feature in a
new way that changed
how our application runs.
So we needed to go
and do something
to answer these questions.
So cloud providers
like Google provide you
this nice advantage.
There's really,
really clear pricing.
Go look at the price sheet to
go see what something costs you.
And they provide you this nice
detailed bill every single day
to tell you what you actually
use and what things cost.
Before I started at Bluecore,
I came from an organization
that owned its own servers.
And so I kind of assumed
that this would not
be a problem in
the cloud universe
because you have this
nice detailed bill.
You want to know
what something costs?
Just look at your bill.
It turns out that that is true
for things that are separate.
So for example, if you have
fairly separable applications,
and you can have, say,
a separate Google Cloud
project for your team
or for your feature,
Google's built-in bill
probably will give you
the level of detail you need.
It will tell you, hey,
this team cost this much.
Here's all the line items
that this team actually used.
And that may actually
be sufficient.
So if that works for
you, that's great.
But there are things
that have to be shared.
In our case, Bluecore
is a software
as a service application.
So at least it's some sort
of high level logical level.
We have one application that is
used by all of our customers.
And so we end up with
some fairly big line
items because of that.
There's other good
examples of this.
One that I really like is
like your data warehouse
for your organization.
The whole point of
your data warehouse
is to put all the data from
your various different pieces
into one database that then
everyone in your organization
can access to be able to learn
the insight that they need to.
By some definition, that has
to be like a shared resource
for your whole organization.
So you're going to end
up with some things that
are shared and are going to
be big line items on your bill
that you may want to go
get more detail about.
So for Bluecore, what
we really wanted is
we really wanted to know
what is our cost per team,
per engineering team.
We want to be able to
have that accountability
to say, hey, these five
people on data science,
your bill went up last month.
Can you go investigate
if that's expected
or if there's a problem here?
Or hey, this email
feature that just got
turned on by this team,
maybe it turns out
that that's more expensive than
we thought it was going to be.
Maybe we need to optimize that.
We also wanted to know what
our cost is per customer.
So we are software as
a service application.
It'd be really nice
for us to look, hey,
for some of our
large customers, what
does it cost us to actually
provide the service to them?
Do we have the
right pricing model?
And our finance team really
wants to know projections.
It turns out that
they would like
to know six months from now,
what is our Google Cloud
bill going to be?
They're really unhappy
when it's changing
all the time, which it is.
So they want to be
able to have some model
to look forward and
say, great, what
is it going to cost us in
six months, or the next year?
What will it cost us if we sign
this particularly large deal
with this particular customer
that has some specific needs?
Can we negotiate or
customize their contract?
We need to know what it's
going to cost us to serve them.
So these things are somewhat
organization specific.
What Bluecore wants
for the cost per team
or our cost per customer is
not what you are going to need.
And but the point is these
are fairly generic things.
And you can sort of
tweak these things
to suit your organization.
So as an overview, here's
what we've done at Bluecore
to break down our bill.
Our step one is put
everything into BigQuery.
We already use BigQuery
a heck of a lot,
so that's a convenient place.
You could put it into
some other thing,
but you need to put
the data in one place
so you can go and analyze it.
We then combine Google's
other data sources
to get some additional
levels of detail.
And we'll talk about more
specific details about which
ones in a moment.
And then step three
is four things
where we don't
have enough detail
from those existing
Google data sources,
we actually go and
instrument the code
to add that level of detail.
The end result is
you can make metrics
that matter to your
team, For Bluecore, it's
that cost per customer or that
cost per engineering team.
But maybe for you,
it's something else.
You can do that by customizing
the existing data that
is available on Google Cloud.
So as a quick example--
sorry for this graph
isn't super visible.
But here's a quick example of
what this actually looks like.
This is our cost by type
over the last 20 days.
This is effectively
our engineering team.
So you can see this top
line at the very top.
This is the email cost.
And you can see that in
February 26, it was fairly high.
And then it actually
decreased because we deployed
some sort of optimization.
And then the next
line here is events.
So you can see for
Bluecore, those are really
the two big cost drivers.
It's ingesting data onto our
platform, which is events,
and then sending
emails, which is email.
There's a bunch of
these other teams
and other line
items at the bottom.
From a cost optimization
perspective,
we can kind of ignore
them because they're
a small part of our bill.
Here's a table that was created
by somebody in our finance team
using this data.
Again, I can't actually
show you any of the data.
So this is just the column
headers off of this table.
This is showing the 25
lowest margin customers,
and I really love this table.
It shows the brand name, the
monthly recurring revenue
for last month, the total
email and event cost, and then
a computed margin.
That is an email
and event margin.
That is how profitable or
unprofitable it is, as well as
the total email [? sense. ?]
The thing I love
about this table
is that our finance team created
this without the engineering
team doing anything.
All we've done is we've
provide this cost per customer
with this email and event cost.
And they combined it
with the existing data
about how much revenue we're
getting per customer to produce
this table.
And this table has
been super useful
because we go and look at
this and be like, hey, why is
customer x costing us so much?
That's really weird.
And then inevitably, when that
happens, we go and look at it.
And it turns out there's some
sort of configuration issue,
or they're using some particular
weird part of the product
in a way that we didn't expect.
And we can go and actually
fix that and actually improve
these problems.
So this has been
super, super helpful.
And again, the part I love
is the engineering team
had nothing to do with this.
The finance team actually
created this themselves.
So this is just an example
of the kind of things
that you can do
once you actually
instrument your bill to the
level of detail that you need.
All right, let's talk about
how we can actually do this.
First, let's talk about the
existing cost management
tools that Google provides.
The first thing that you
really should look at--
and certainly, I look
at-- for any cost problem
is the Google Cloud
billing reports.
Bluecore has been a Google
Cloud customer for long enough
that this billing report
did not used to exist.
It does now exist.
It's actually useful.
If you haven't played
with it, you should.
It looks like the screenshot
shown here on the right.
It will show you your cost
per project, per service,
per line item or SKU, sliced
over different time ranges.
It lets you slice and
dice this how you want.
It's pretty useful.
The part that is
still unfortunate,
though, is that
there are things,
like this big blue
bar here at the top,
that it can't provide you any
more detail than the line item
and project level.
So why is this big
blue bar so high?
We're going to have to go do
some work to figure that out.
So the first step
to figuring out
why the heck this single
line item is so large
is to get the actual raw data.
This is where the
billing export comes in.
This lets you get your detailed
cost data exported directly
to BigQuery.
There's also a JSON export.
I don't find that
to be as useful.
If there's one thing that
you take away from this,
you should go turn
this feature on today.
The reason is you
can't go back in time
and get the detailed billing
data for data in the past.
So if you are going to want to
do cost analysis at some point
in the next, say,
year and are going
to want to look back at
cost data from today,
you need to go
turn this on today.
It probably won't
cost you anything
if you're not using
BigQuery very much anyway.
What it gives you is it gives
you this sort of detailed data
that's shown on the right.
We're going to talk a little
bit about it in a moment,
about the actual
Google Cloud bill.
And there's some sort
of schema for this.
There's lots of documentation.
OK, so what do you get when you
actually-- if you're actually
working with this data,
how should you actually
work with it?
A few tips that are useful
to know-- first thing
is Google bills you.
The Google's
official billing time
is Pacific time days, so
Mountain View standard time.
You can convert the billing
data into this time zone
by using this BigQuery
function here, TIMESTAMP_TRUNC.
Take the usage start time, and
convert it into this America
Los Angeles time zone.
Now you'll get days that are the
same days that Google actually
uses, which is
useful when you want
to compare this to your bill.
Some of the data is delayed.
It's a small percentage.
It keeps decreasing.
Last I looked before
making this talk,
in February, it was
something like 0.1%.
Usually, that data is
delayed only by a day or two.
Sometimes it's a little
bit more, but not much.
The point here is if you
want to use this data,
you're going to have to
process chunks of time,
or reprocess it, or delay
your processing a little bit
to make sure that you
actually capture all of it.
Tax and corrections
show up much later.
Tax shows up at the
end of the month.
If you have
corrections or credits,
they will show up way later.
This can also screw
up your analysis.
So you may end up having
to, again, reprocess
this data multiple times to
sort of get the correct view.
And the other thing
is this schema
has human descriptions in it.
It has a sku.description
and a product.description.
And these can change.
The most recent change
was Google changed this
from calling it
standard instance CPU
and standard instance RAM
to predefined instance
CPU and RAM.
This is totally fine if you're
doing some ad hoc analysis
and just looking at what
was the cost last week.
If you're trying to do some
analysis over, say, a year,
you're going to want to use the
ID fields that Google provides.
And now the problem
is that those
aren't human understandable.
OK.
What does it actually look like?
So let's go and
recreate this graph
from the Google billing report.
This is showing us the top
SKUs by day this month.
These are their top Google
Cloud billing line items
for the current month
broken down each day.
So that was what the screenshot
was that we showed before
on the left hand side.
And on the right hand side is
this sort of BigQuery results
that we want, which have
the day, as well as then
the actual line item here,
like the frontend instance,
data store, Cloud data
store read operations.
What does this look like?
Here's the example query.
You don't have to understand it.
I am going to walk through
a couple of the parts that
are somewhat
important to give you
a sense about what the actual
raw Google billing data looks
like.
The first thing
here is this day.
This is this magic conversion
to Google standard billing days.
So TIMESTAMP_TRUNC, that
you should start time
to this America Los
Angeles time zone.
Again, we want to
actually go and compare
to our actual Google Cloud bill.
You're going to want
to convert to that day
if you want to be able do that.
This SKU description, this is
this human readable description
of that line item.
And then we want to sum
our cost in this sort
of magic expression here with
this coalesce unnest thing.
It's BigQuery magic to say,
hey, take the credits that
are attached to that line
item, and just sum them
all up as well.
So when you have credits,
like say the sustained usage
discount in Compute
Engine, there
can be multiple credits
attached to a single line item.
We want to add all of
those credits together
to get the actual cost after
the credits have been applied.
We want to take the sum of
days since the beginning
of the month.
So that's this timestamp
trunc to the month
and this partition time magic.
Again, you don't have
to understand this.
And then we want to
sum all these together.
The final result is going
to look something like this.
This is Bluecore's actual
top line items for March 16.
Frontend instances--
that's App Engine CPU.
Google Cloud Data Store read
operations, backend instances--
that's also App Engine CPU.
And then BigQuery
flat rate annual,
we're a big BigQuery user, so
we pay for flat rate pricing.
Great.
So now we've just recreated
what the billing report already
gives us.
So who cares?
What's the point?
Well, the point is
we can now actually
go and do additional analysis.
And one of the things
that you might want to do,
if you're a little
bit crazy, is actually
go reproduce your exact invoice.
Now this sounds a little
silly, and I admit it is.
It doesn't serve a whole
lot of practical purpose,
but it is very useful to be
able to verify that whatever
conversions or
analysis you're doing
is actually correct by matching
your Google Cloud bill.
If you want to do
this craziness,
Google provides you some tools
to make it actually easy.
First is it provides this
invoice.month field, which
gives you a year and month
string, which is exactly
which invoice that particular
record is going to end up
on from Google's bill.
So you can group by that.
The second thing you're
going to want to do
is you need to round
your cost and credits
to two decimal places at the
line item or the SKU level.
So this is this round
to two decimal points
BigQuery expression there.
Finally, the export data will
show tax as one line item
at the beginning
of the next month,
whereas if you look
at your PDF bill,
it will actually show you
your tax on separate projects.
So if you're comparing your PDF
bill to your BigQuery results
and really want it
to add up, you're
going to have to do
a little bit of math.
And if you do this, you actually
get exactly to your bill
down to the exact penny
since December 2018.
There's a document in Google's
billing documentation,
which will show you some
exact query examples.
Again, is this
actually that useful?
It's useful for
debugging things.
But for the most part,
if you don't do this,
you're going to get within
the nearest dollar anyway.
So you don't necessarily have to
do this, unless you're like me,
and are kind of anal retentive,
and want to really make sure
that you got it right.
OK, so now, what
can we do with this?
We have our raw billing
data export into BigQuery.
We would now want to
actually go and look at it
and be able to
produce some reports.
I suggest that you
use Data Studio.
Again, it's built into Google
Cloud, available for you
for free.
This is not a talk
about Data Studio.
I'm not going to tell you how
to use it or show it to you.
There's lots of other talks
and resources about this.
Again, the billing documentation
itself provides some examples.
But the point here is you can
now create custom dashboards
from this billing data.
The reason this is useful
is that there sometimes
are things in the built-in
Google billing tool
that you may want to come
back to multiple times.
Maybe you want to look at here's
the top cost for our production
project, combined with some
cost for some of our top line
items in a separate chart.
You can create a
dashboard in Data Studio
just by pointing and clicking.
Save that as a link,
share it with others,
look at it every single day.
So again, this is
still the same data
that's available in that
billing report thing.
But now you can
customize it to look
at stuff that is
actually relevant to you
and make that easier.
I also just find Data
Studio to be a useful tool
to know about if you
need to do some ad
hoc visualization of BigQuery
stuff or other data sources
anyway.
So it's useful to play with.
OK.
So this is basically the
built-in Google Cloud billing
tools.
So now let's talk about
what other data sources
we might want to use to
get more detail on this.
So as a reminder,
the point here is,
we have these big line
items that are left.
So, for example,
this big blue bar--
what the heck is in this thing?
We'd like to know more detail
about where that's coming from.
So there are other
data sources about what
you're using on Google Cloud
that you can go and pull
some of this from.
Some examples on App Engine,
you have request logs
that tell you every request
that came into your application.
For BigQuery, there
are query logs that
tell you about every
query that got executed.
For Pub/Sub, there are
Stackdriver metrics
that tell you about
the total bytes going
into and out of your topics.
For Kubernetes
Storage and Compute,
there are usage exports
that will tell you
various granularities of
usage data about those things.
And so we can go and combine
these existing usage data
things with our bill
to find out what
are in those big line items.
So here's the plan.
We're going to get
the usage per day
for one of these
large line items
that we want to
understand in more detail.
We're then going to
combine that information
with our official bill to get
a usage metric per dollar.
And then we're going to
produce an annotated bill that
has that original
data from Google a lot
but broken out into
these separate categories
with this additional annotation.
So the exact way
you do this is going
to depend a little
bit on the resource
that you want to break down.
I'm going to talk through what
we did for App Engine CPU,
just because that is for Google,
this is the largest line item.
Or for us, Siri.
For Bluecore, the largest
line item that we have.
The largest line item
we have currently
is App Engine frontend
instances, which
is CPU time on App Engine.
We started five or six years ago
as an App Engine application.
It's still our biggest
line item today.
So how do we do this?
App Engine has these requests
logs, and they look like this.
You do not need to understand
what is on this slide,
but the point is there's a whole
lot of data in this existing
request log.
And when we were
looking at this,
we noticed, hey, there's
this line item here
that says mega cycles 29.
What the heck is that?
If you look it up in
this documentation,
it says something like this is
a suggestion of how much CPU
is used by this request.
But it's actually
not very accurate.
User be warned.
So we wanted to
know, OK, well, this
says it may or may
not be accurate.
What can we do with it?
So we went to Data
Studio and produced
a visualization of our total
App Engine cost at the top.
So this is the data from the
Google Cloud billing export
per day for this one line item.
And then we went and
summed this mega cycles
value out of the
App Engine request
logs over that same time period.
And so what do you see when
you see these two graphs?
To me, that's pretty damn close.
If you look at these
two blobs here,
you'll notice that they're not
actually completely identical.
There's a little bit of
difference between these two
things.
But that's pretty close.
So fine.
Maybe there's some error here.
Maybe we're off by 1%.
Maybe we're off by 5%.
I'm not sure.
But this seems like
this is probably
a useful data source for us.
And in some
experimentation that we've
done by fixing some
things, we've sort of
verified that it is close.
So now what do we do?
Well, what we can do
is sum the mega cycles
per day out of this App
Engine log to get a total.
And then we can compute what
the cost per mega cycle per day
was.
So 10,000 mega cycles per
dollar, something like this.
Now we can actually compute
the cost for each request
because each request has
this mega cycles value on it.
And we can aggregate
these URL pads
by team and by customer to
break down the annotation
to get that level of
detail that we want.
There's going to be
some stuff left over.
And in our case, we just
account this to unknown
because we're not going to
get 100% of our coverage.
And again, that's OK.
That's one of the
points here, is
we don't need this to be
completely 100% accurate.
We just need it to be like
90% accurate or 95% accurate.
So what does this look like?
Well, we end up--
oh, sorry.
The next part, I
should point out,
is this is actually
a relative cost.
I don't actually know how much
does a mega cycle cost you?
I don't know.
Google doesn't tell us.
It doesn't really make sense.
But as a relative
usage, a fraction
of our usage of App
Engine resources,
it's a useful measure.
And there's lots of other
resources that sort of look
like this as well,
where you can say, well,
this is a percentage of
our cost for this day.
And you can break
it out that way.
So what this looks like is this
proves the table that has, say,
each day.
In this case, this
is March 18th.
A URL path or a URL
prefix, and then a cost
that it cost us for that
particular URL prefix.
So when we've gone and done
this for Bluecore's bill,
our App Engine CPU annotation
gets us about 38% of our bill.
We get that sort of
team customer breakdown
for 38% from that.
We've also had to go and do
this annotation for BigQuery
queries.
Like I said, that was our
number four line item.
So we do the sort of
same thing by looking
at the BigQuery query log.
And we've also done this
for Data Store storage
by looking at this Data Store
storage export data or usage
data that we then export
out of Data Store.
When we do it for
these three line items,
we now have 49%
of our bill that's
left where we don't have
this team and customer
level of detail.
So this isn't quite good enough.
We got 51%, but we still need to
know what's in some of this 49%
before we know that we have
an accurate enough estimate
of our costs per
team or per customer.
So what can we do now?
We're going to have to
go instrument our code
to get more detail about what's
in that remaining bucket.
So here's our plan.
We're going to go and
instrument our code.
We're going to go and instrument
our application in some way.
We're going to admit that data.
In our case, we
admit it in logs,
which then end up in BigQuery
through the Stackdriver logging
export.
And then we're going to
go aggregate this usage
data by day, which will then
look like what we did before
with Google's own data sources.
We're going to get
some amount of usage
for these additional line items
on a daily basis, which we
can then combine with the bill.
So as an example, we did this
for Data Store gets and puts.
Like I said, we're an
App Engine application.
This is another large
line item for us.
It was the original sort of
storage layer for App Engine.
And the way you get charged for
it is you get charged for every
get you do and every put you
do against this operation.
So we want to count
how many we have.
So we have to go and
wrap in our application
all the get and
put calls to count
how many actually happened.
We then log the counts at
the end of each web request,
so that we can find out for
that particular request, how
many did we actually do.
And then we aggregate these in
BigQuery using its JSON extract
function which lets you pull
fields out of JSON payloads.
So the log that we
emit looks something
like this, where
we have a counts
section with the various
counts we care about.
In this case, this is data
store gets and data store puts.
And then we also attach
this namespace thing.
So this is from
our application, we
have a concept of
a namespace, which
basically maps to the customer.
And so this is why we actually
do this on a per request basis,
is so that we can get back down
to that level of granularity
of a single customer.
And then we can run
BigQuery queries
across our logs to basically
sum these up and aggregate those
together.
So what does this look like?
Well, now we can get a
table that looks something
like this, where we produce
for a single day in a URL path
or prefix, how many
gets and puts we did.
These are absolute costs.
Google tells us how much
these actually cost.
So now these just translate
directly into dollars.
So this is actually a little
bit easier than the case
where you only have a relative
cost metric, where you have
sort of a fraction of usage.
This one, we can just basically
do the math and say, great,
this URL prefix cost
this much because
of the price from Google.
So here's what our
actual detailed cost
schema looks like.
This is the sort of final output
of all of these series of jobs
that we've done.
This may or may not
be the ideal schema.
It's worked for us.
Hopefully, you can use
it for some inspiration.
If you come up with a
better one, please tell me.
I'd love to know.
So what does this look like?
The first most important
field is this usageDayPacific.
This matches Google's
billing days.
So this is this Mountain
View standard time,
day from our bill.
The next fields we pull out are
the project, service, and SKU
or line item.
These are the dimensions
from the billing exports.
These are fields that we
group by from Google's
original billing data.
We then pull out the cost,
usage amount, and credits.
These are the metrics from
Google's billing data.
So we sum these out of
Google's existing bill.
The cost is the actual cost.
Usage amount is some
per service metric.
So for Data Store, it'll
be read operations.
For Google Cloud Storage,
it'll be gigabytes seconds
or something like this.
And then credits are
the credit value.
And the key part
that we've done is
we have two additional custom
dimensions that we've added.
So we, again, had
this namespace,
which for us is
effectively a customer.
And this cost category,
which is basically
a software component,
which we can then
map back to a particular team.
And the constraint
that we try to continue
to make sure we meet here
is that if we sum this table
on some of these
dimensions, that it
adds up back to Google's bill.
So we're adding these
custom dimensions
as additional
detail on the bill.
So how do we actually
produce this?
So we get some
original billing data.
So as an example, we
have a particular day,
March 18th, a particular--
it'll actually be a project
in a SKU, but for simplicity,
I'm just showing the SKU here--
datastore gets.
And we have some sort
of cost for this,
so it cost us
$2,000 on that day.
We then have instrumented
our application
to produce this usage data
of showing for that day
some URL path did 2,400 gets,
some URL path did 29,000 gets.
And again, we can translate
that back to cost.
So we can combine
these two things
to produce this annotated bill,
which now has three line items.
So it has one datastore gets
for, let's say, Team A. We have
some mapping from
these URLs paths
back to these cost
categories or teams
and how much that actually cost.
We have datastore
gets for Team B.
And then again, there's
going to be some left over.
We don't instrument every
single application that we run.
We just try to
instrument the big users,
and so there's some left over.
In this case, say $363.
And again, that's OK.
We don't need to be perfect.
We just need to get
most of it in order
to be able to make the right
optimization decisions.
So now that we've
done this, we managed
to cover 51% of our
bill just by using
Google's built-in other
usage data sources.
So we were able to get 51%
of our bill down to this team
and customer level
without necessarily going
to instrument our application.
And at Bluecore, we've
then gone and instrumented
a couple of data sources.
So datastore reads and
writes is one example.
There's a couple of others
that we've done as well.
That gets us another 24% of our
total bill down to this cost
category and customer level.
There's going to
be some left over.
In our case, it's
currently about 25%.
And in our case, this
percentage continues to grow.
This remaining bucket
continues to grow over time.
And our approach has been
once it gets too large,
we go and look at it
and figure out what
do we have to instrument next.
What usage data
can we import next?
And the point, again,
here is you don't
have to be perfect about it.
We just need to
get it right enough
and get enough of
the data correct.
And for us, this is
sort of accurate enough.
Great.
So now let's talk a little
bit about some of the lessons
that we've learned through
going and doing this.
The first one is you really
want to break cost down to teams
because that is what actually
makes metrics actionable,
is when you can get
the responsibility down
to a small enough
pool of people.
What is small enough?
It's kind of going to
depend on your organization.
But in Bluecore's case, when it
was 40 engineers and we said,
hey, datastore costs went up
last week, that was too large.
Everyone just sort of
looked around and been like,
I don't know.
It wasn't my problem.
You need to get it down to a
small enough group of people
so that when you say that to
someone, they're like, oh,
actually we did
something last week.
Maybe we should look at this.
As an example, here's a cost
for one line item over 24 days.
This starts at zero.
It goes up to a
question mark number.
And when I look at this,
I say, maybe something
happened there at the end.
I don't know.
There's a lot of variation.
So this is what our
bill looked like.
I can't remember.
I think this was in January.
Here is that same line item.
If we look at just
the responsibility
for one team for
one cost category,
again, this starts at zero.
This is the same 24 days.
And you can now tell, holy crap,
this went up by a factor of 2
for this particular team.
Maybe we should go
and look at this.
Sure enough, we
went to look at it.
Here's that same team's
SKU over 46 days.
We went and fixed the problem.
The cost went back down
to normal after this.
So this is just
an example of you
need to get the metrics to
the level of granularity that
work for your organization.
So that you can go and
look at something and say,
hey, there's definitely
something wrong here.
It's definitely in
this particular part
of our product or our software.
Let's go and fix the problem.
This actually leads to
another interesting part,
is in the cloud
when you are using
a lot of these automatic
scaling features,
performance bugs actually
become cost bugs.
And I think this
is actually great.
This is actually an improvement.
In the old world when you had
a performance problem, where
your load went up,
there was some sort
of error retrying or customer
load when that happened,
your service just went down.
So you knew about the
problem right away.
But it also meant that your
application was broken,
and your service was broken.
If you're using a lot of
these auto scaling things,
your service is just
going to continue to work.
It just might cost
you a heck of a lot.
So you do need to keep an
eye on these sorts of things
to be able to find these
problems before they cost you
a lot of money.
There are built-in Google
features for this, by the way.
There are billing
alerts that you
can set on various
levels of granularity.
There are all sorts of
other things you can do.
Finally, my big point
is, again, make metrics
that matter for your team.
What has worked for
Bluecore may or may not
work for you and your team.
But the data is there.
You can go and do it.
You can break it down to the
level of granularity you want.
It is possible to go and
annotate this stuff to figure
out where your usage is going.
You just have to go do
a little bit of work,
and it's not actually that hard.
To learn more today,
there's a couple
of other sessions still left.
10:20, there's Automated
Cost Optimizations on GCP.
1:15, there's Aligning Cloud
Costs with Service Delivery.
You can go to the cost
management showcase
and talk to some
of the Google PMs
who are working on
these sorts of things.
And if you have
questions about it,
there's the Ask
the Expert booth.
And definitely go and look
at the cost management
documentation on Google
Cloud on cloud.google.com.
It has details about all this
stuff that I talked about
today, like how to set up and
use the billing export, what
does the scheme actually mean.
[MUSIC PLAYING]